the White House has a major leak problem
let me first talk generally about it so
in general when you get White House
leaks you get them sporadically and
usually they're meant to help the
leakers maybe gain power out of
self-interest so you might have a White
House staffer that leaks something with
the sort of general goal of maybe
helping themselves in some way by
discrediting a White House staffer or
something like that in the Trump era
just in the first five weeks of the
administration we're seeing leaks that
very clearly are happening because some
administrative staffers are just
genuinely horrified by what's going on
in the Trump administration and as a
result Sean Spicer column a regular old
Sherlock Holmes started an investigation
into who might be leaking stuff from the
Trump administration and Spicer warned
White House officials not to leak the
fact that he was running an
investigation into leaks to the media in
other words he wanted to keep the leak
investigation private it was almost
immediately leaked Spicer's
investigation into leaks was leaked and
it's endlessly hilarious Spicer
reportedly held a surprise search of
staffer phones to try to find leakers
and he called people into his office he
said that they had to leave their phones
and mobile devices on a table to be
searched to ensure that nobody has
anything to hide almost immediately
countless stories pop up on social media
about how Sean Spicer is trying to find
leakers Spicer was asked to comment
about the leak story about the leaked
meeting the subject of which was finding
bleeker's and stopping leaks he didn't
want to comment about that how great is
this Spicer called staffers in for a
meeting to complain about leaks and then
news of the meeting is leaked it's like
playing whack-a-mole where you're trying
to slam down roles as they pop off the
carnival game and then another one just
pops up and you try to slam down leaks
and then leaks about the leaks or just
popping up I love it I mean can we
really be surprised though this is the
guy who tweeted out his password not
once but twice I didn't even know that
was really possible I got to believe
Shawn spices the next to go in the Trump
administration I think he's on the
chopping block I think it's been clear
from the beginning yeah I mean to embed
eres the Trump administration is a hard
task and I think he's doing a good job
of it you couldn't do a Saturday Night
Live parody of this because it's a
parody of itself like what detail could
you change if you were to parody a
leaked investigation into leaks and it's
pretty clear why people are leaking
right not only are people scared about
what's going on but it appears that
Spicer is a true nightmare to work with
and as part of the report on the leaked
leaked investigation it was also
reported that during a recent staff
meeting Spicer started really
aggressively criticizing the work of
deputy communications director Jessica
did oh and it caused her to just start
crying according to two people familiar
with the incident I get the sense that
maybe Sean Spicer is putting his
failings on other people because you're
right he's been an absolute train wreck
I mean he seems like a bully who is also
bullied himself and in this case he's
you know attacking the people below him
but also getting blowback from Trump
himself the entire calling people in to
start checking who might be leaking and
say don't leak the leak investigation it
struck me as epitomizing that often
repeated I don't even know what it is at
this point phrase quote the beatings
will continue until morale improves that
strikes me as the sort of mo of Sean
Spicer in some way and I don't see
things as I guess that's where I come
down on it which is it's hard to imagine
things getting things getting much
better within the Sean Spicer press
world of the Trump White House with Sean
Spicer still there doesn't it feel like
it's just irrecoverable at this point
unless you replace Spicer with someone
else I think it was from the first day I
mean how do you you go out in the first
day and you talk about the inauguration
crowd sites and get the numbers
completely wrong and don't take any
questions and leave you can't even
recover from that yeah he didn't lie as
well as Trump wanted him to trump wanted
him to go out there and somehow convince
people that he had record turnout at his
inauguration and then Trump was
displeased with the job that Sean Spicer
did blatantly lying to the public if you
send the guy out to blatantly lie about
verifiable facts how well could the guy
possibly do it was sort of
he was set up to fail by Trump Kellyanne
Conway does a good job of it sir she
seems to although she's missing she's
nowhere to be to be found since the
Bowling Green Massacre debacle